just the whole story of getting it made
was one whole thing but then once we got
it made to have Robin sign up to do it
was really that's really what got us a
green light and we wrote that movie
specifically Ben and I wrote it because
we wanted the parts as actors and at the
time there was a really popular movie
that we all loved called Reservoir Dogs
and the story we had heard was that
because Harvey Keitel signed up for the
movie Quentin got I think it was half a
million dollars that was his budget he
could make the movie and so we wrote
that part that Robin eventually took we
called it the Harvey Keitel part and I
just have so many memories of that guy
as writers like he was a guy who could
come in and just throw lines out for
instance the last line of that movie he
reads a letter for me and he says [ __ ]
stole my life that wasn't scripted Robin
just did that we had scripted that he
just kind of sits there and takes it in
and realizes that my character is gone
and he didn't say anything he just kind
of took that moment and the one that's
in the movie he just said son of a [ __ ]
he stole my line